all right it's time for hatred mail
hydroxychloroquine playing a big role in
hatred mail this week both in our new
introduction as well as today's hatred
mail itself quick reminder what is
hatred mail why don't you take some
hydroxychloroquine for that trump
derangement syndrome patriot man written
by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom all
right so this week's hatred mail is
particularly unhinged and it actually
relates to some of the stories that
we've got coming up next let's take a
listen to it together as I like to say
Wow Pakman is what who watches this crap
Obama showed the world what a penny
waste we can be you're worse than the
young turds Magga 2020 Pakman is
evidence of what happens when the vegan
diets soy boy I was disgusted when David
Pakman pretended to believe accusers you
want to help build the genocide genius
gate sell his antivirus injections fine
but let us have our chloroquine yeah so
you may have noticed that we don't hear
donald trump mentioning chloroquine
anymore unless someone forces him to
talk about it
Fox News is barely talking about it
anymore although they did do one segment
about it this morning which I will be
playing for you later and it's because
there are more and more studies showing
not only that it doesn't appear to be
particularly efficacious but it may
actually increase death rates very very
scary stuff and we will follow up about
how this has been propagandized around
now for a full month or maybe even five
weeks we will discuss shortly remember
the best way to fight hatreds in your
community is to use the coupon code hate
reott for tea whenever you sign up for a
membership and join pakman.com that
coupon code saves you 40% the hey tree
it's hated its h80 our iot for 0